ne vous fiez pas aux apparences
nous sommes bien dans un collège depuis
2009 à poligny les espaces verts ont été
progressivement converti en espace de
vie
avec leur professeur de sciences et vie
de la terre les élèves sont en prise
directe avec les principes de
développement durable ce jour là c'est
la première récolte dans le verger
planté il ya maintenant sept ans arrache
pas n'importe comment si vous tirez
comme un beurre vous avez cassé des
branches vous avez blessés l'arbre comme
en ont connu une pomme
on l'a tous exactement
je préfère être ici que dans un autre
collège on apprend des choses pas que
avec l'école mais aussi en dehors avec
tout ce qui est on peut faire des
projets et c est pas tous les collèges
le faut on allait courir on
peut aussi apprendre à
se nourrir à récolter plus tard
on va voir les
abeilles qui pollinisent les arbres ok
la reproduction des plantes c'est au
programme les élèves l'apprennent et la
voie en vrai
c'est plus un lieu où juste on
[Musique]
ingurgite des choses qu'on nous donne
mais c'est aussi un endroit où on fait
des choses et on s'implique dans le
réacteur de base du lieu donc je pense
que c'est une façon de s'approprier le
lieu d'en faire un espèce de chez soi
quoi et ça je pense que pour qu'un élève
se sentent bien quelque part il faut qu
ils considèrent que c'est chez lui
légumes fruits miel tout est donnée à la
cantine connu aussi pour ses actions
anti gaspillage
se sentir bien en cours c'est aussi
l'objectif de gladys du chanois depuis
trois ans à morteau est la mise en place
une classe flexible pour enseigner
l'histoire la géo et le français à ces
lycéens en filière professionnelle des
élèves qui sont libres d'aller et venir
exactement on peut on peut servir qu'on
veut ce genre on appelle tous les
travailleurs en collectif qu'on doit
faire et du coup on s'est dit qu'on
allait prendre un petit café ont
travaillé pour moi a plus tendance on
peut se mettre tout seul ou en groupe on
peut travailler tranquillement c'est ça
que j'aime pas de cours dictée c'est aux
élèves de trouver l'information
ils peuvent utiliser leur téléphone pour
aller sur des sites recommandés
quatre décennies et ben oui c'est ce que
je vous donne marque au tableau donc
comme au bac tout ce qui pourra être
croquis dessins pied en rapport avec le
sujet et ça ça permet de faire grimper
votre moto vague en vrai c'est beaucoup
mieux de faire ça parce que tout le
temps actuel au bout d'un moment ça
devient chaud du coup on apprend mieux
comme ça et puis c'est plus sympa
une classe flexible c'est aussi un
endroit où l'on peut s'isoler
l'essentiel est de se sentir bien ça
permet de mieux comprendre en classe de
d'apprendre plus vite où ils vont
chercher les informations il les met sur
la forme de la carte mentale ensuite ils
font de synthèse rédigée donc on a quand
même déjà trois étapes répéter et puis
ensuite il va y avoir l'apprentissage à
la maison qu'on va faire sur un court
terme donc il va y avoir une évaluation
qui va tomber assez rapidement et puis
une évaluation sur le long terme qui va
refiler veux leur demander de reprendre
sa ces enseignants prennent du temps et
des risques pour changer l'école comme
leurs élèves ils se sentent eux aussi
bien dans leur travail